resuelve el valor absoluto de 3 x 9
igual a 0 y gráficas la solución en una
recta numérica y bueno date cuenta que
aquí tenemos una ecuación con valor
absoluto el valor absoluto de 3x menos 9
esto es igual a 0 sin embargo date
cuenta que algo muy importante si digo
que el valor absoluto de algo es igual a
cero pues esto que está dentro del valor
absoluto no tiene la trama tiene que ser
igual a cero porque el único número al
cual al aplicarle el valor absoluto nos
da cero es cero por lo tanto me queda
que 3x menos 9 esto tiene que ser igual
a 0 y si 3x menos 9 tiene que ser igual
a cero esta ecuación ya es muy fácil de
resolver lo único que hay que hacer es
despejar a x lo importante de esta
ecuación con valor absoluto es entender
que el valor absoluto de algo igual a
cero esto implica que ese algo es decir
lo que está dentro del mayor absoluto es
cero es la única forma de que teníamos
esta solución y bueno sí ya tengo que 3x
menos 9 es igual a cero pues voy a sumar
9 de ambos lados de la ecuación y que me
va a quedar estos dos se van y lo que
hacen precisamente que 3x es igual a 9 y
después divido a ambos lados entre 3 me
queda que estos dos se van 303 me da 11
x xx y después 9 entre 33 x igual a 3 es
el valor que soluciona esta ecuación si
yo pongo x 3 en esta ecuación voy a
obtener como respuesta a cero pues
después dice que también lo grafica
hemos en una recta numérica así que
déjame hacer aquí en directa numérica y
aquí voy a poner menos dos menos 1 0 1 2
3 4 5 y hasta 6 podremos seguirle en fin
pero yo lo único que quiero es poner un
pequeño punto cuando x vale 3 porque esa
es mi única solución cuando x vale 3 con
un pequeño punto y ya está
tengo la gráfica de esta solución